how do you feel about muscular and
Twitter by the way how do you feel about
the whole concept of mosque buying
Twitter and he lost all these
advertisers I think musk lost two
yesterday he lost a general uh GM he
lost Pfizer he lost uh Audi he lost a
bunch of guys he said every day we're
losing how much money they says
Twitter's losing four million dollars a
day some number like that he tweeted out
yesterday that they're losing four
million dollars a day and it's unfair
that this is happening uh right there uh
Twitter has a massive drop in Revenue
due to activist groups Russian
advertisers even though nothing has
changed in accounting moderation and we
did everything we could to piece the
active is extremely messed up they're
trying to destroy free speech in America
and then later on he says that they're
losing four million dollars a day but
how do you feel about the fact that he's
buying Twitter well let me bought
Twitter let me tell you what I saw today
that really encouraged me go to go to a
guy on Twitter his name is Mike Davis
and he tweets out to Elon Musk and he
basically says that
um he has a solution to this Advertiser
problem and it comes back to Twitter
followers so go down to Mike Davis
replying to Elon Musk
uh and then Elon Musk replied to Davis
today
uh
uh okay he goes um let me see if you can
find it um
I think that's it uh one second yeah
there we go there we go
um can you zoom in
no no that's not it keep going keep
going down
um
man these days people tweet a lot so
it's not so easy to find is it a reply
or is it a tweet give me a second yeah
you know what and then I'll go okay I
just found a dear Elon Musk you have 140
million Twitter followers is that the
one that's it name and shame the
advertisers who are uh succumb
succumbing to The Advertiser boycotts so
we can counter boycott them and get your
eight dollars a month monthly
subscription go on ASAP so we can start
to make up for losses of Revenue and
then read elon's reply
responds back
uh uh I actually don't see his reply I
only see his I don't see what Elon said
okay
um what did Elon say basically Elon goes
oh there you go thank you a thermal uh
thermonuclear name and Shane is exactly
what will happen if this continues right
so this tells me that Elon Musk
recognizes that there is a big battle
over free speech in America and the
question becomes I mean he brings
incredible resources to it what I didn't
know is does he bring the will to fight
this out because these people are
determined to protect the regime of
censorship and he's so I'm very high on
Elon Musk I think it's fantastic that he
bought Twitter
um Twitter has suddenly become a free
speech platform for the most part even
though Elon says our moderation policies
haven't changed I think the word is out
that this is now a free speech platform
and see that puts pressure now on
YouTube and Facebook because because in
the free market of big platforms versus
censorship platforms it's hard for me to
see censorship platforms winning long
term
so they they're able to agree they are
able to win if they can all coordinate
with each other so you don't have an
alternative just like you can make your
product successful you just lost a big
one though exactly they just lost the
big one by losing Twitter right so they
can't now all come together by the way
you know what I told them yesterday I
said to Elon when he was saying this I
tweeted back I said you're the right guy
for the job I said the hate you got with
Tesla got you PhD in handling hate the
hate you're about to get with Twitter
will earn you your own planet
and that's that's that's what's going
because he's about to get it times a
thousand right endless go ahead Tom no
you've seen things like this it's like
you take a look at OPEC OPEC worked in
the 70s even in the 80s but then all it
took was one which was usually oh man or
UAE to be shipping oil at night remember
these days and they broke from OPEC and
the Venezuela broke from OPAC and then
OPAC was was sort of a general pricing
arm they were not a supply arm anymore
remember those days and so I think right
now the supply and the pricing of social
media has been I I think has been not in
the lock step but it's been together and
I think it's fracturing everywhere and
also Facebook doesn't have the new
generation Facebook has its own problems
of long-term relevancy without worrying
about censorship in my view
and with with Rumble you now have a real
alternative to YouTube so YouTube is
still much bigger but rumble's been
growing well and so the game is changing
on the Free Speech front so if you like
this clip and you want to watch another
one click right here and if you want to
watch the entire podcast click right
here
[Music]